Je voulais que le public soit
plongé au milieu d'un
environnement riche très très spécifique très capiteux
c'est le jour des morts partout où vous
regardez il y a de la couleur et des détails dans la vie
nous avons construit des chars et des chats et un
costume extraordinaire et le
savoir-faire  est incroyable nous sommes allés au
Mexique et avons trouvé des gens incroyables là-bas
c'est leur culture alors ils ont dû m'apprendre
je leur ai dit s'il vous plaît faites-le à votre façon et
ensuite ils ont travaillé pendant six mois mais le
résultat est à couper le souffle chaque veste était
créative par personne les robes nous
vraiment essayé de les rendre tous différents
et apportant toujours comme la mort dans
ce costume,
nous avons 1 500 extras, ce qui est tout à fait
unique maintenant pour faire un don en costume dont l'
étude publicitaire cgi ne devrait pas faire plus de 5 ou
6, donc le truc est à travers ce Fox et
c'est  un minimum de temps pour
préparer quelqu'un nous l'avons fait ce matin en
75 minutes pour 1 500 c'est 20 par minute
j'y vais je pense que le
nombre est assez décourageant
la liberté de création un  et cela a été
incroyable fantastique est qui d'autre mais il
ne voudrait pas les faire dans le dáil donc
l'avoir capturé dans un film Bond et
je suis comme Juanico Cuisine est fantastique
tout le monde a été vraiment utile
toute la communauté c'était incroyable  et
très honoré d'avoir l'ouverture du
film de James Bond au Mexique donc nous sommes
vraiment ravis de voir les résultats je
ne pourrais pas être plus heureux c'est le plus incroyable
et leur qualité de travail est incroyable
ça va être le plus
excitant visuellement pour un étang
vous